Jorge Ramos seven-time Emmy
award-winning news anchor of noticiero
Univision moved to the u.s. from Mexico
when he was 25 and has lived here for 20
years no border is his memoir of
immigration this talk from Miami Book
Fair international is 50 minutes and all
I'm we're gonna start this good evening
as I explained just a few moments ago
we're gonna be doing everything in
English that was a commitment with a
fair and later on if you have questions
in Spanish we'll go to Spanish and even
better if you want to do it in Spanglish
I mean that's what we speak here in
Miami so when they asked me to to give
this presentation in English I I thought
I mean how can they even phantom of the
idea of Mexican journalist speaking in
English in Miami I mean what do they
want and then maybe this reflects the
incredible changes that we are living in
in a city like Miami the incredible
changes that we see in South Florida and
how all the United States is being
transformed but despite everything and
despite the fact that I've been here for
20 years and as you can see I still have
a thick accent my son Nicholas was here
and my daughter Paola I mean they don't
have an axe and they are completely
bilingual so whenever I bring my
daughter Paola
to some of the events she tells me well
that maybe that word was not perfectly
pronounced and then she corrects me but
what's interesting is that we are living
in such a fantastic country a
multi-ethnic multicultural country
multiracial that everything everything
is permitted
now despite the fact that I've been
living in this country for 20 years now
I still feel like an immigrant think
about it I am a Mexican therefore I'm a
minority or a member of a minority in
the midst of another minority which is a
Cuban American community in the Cuban
American communities and other minority
within the Latino community which by the
way
another minority so I'm a triple
minority and even 20 years after I
arrived in the United States I still
feel like an immigrant sometimes I feel
like I do not belong neither to Miami or
to Florida or to the United States when
I talked to some people who when I have
to travel a lot to different cities and
states in the United States when they
listen to my accent they always want to
know where are you from I mean they
cannot even think that I'm from the
United States when I'm they know that
I'm a foreigner and therefore I get this
sense this strange sense that I do not
belong sometimes to the United States
even though my my son was born here and
my daughter was born here and my wife is
from Puerto Rico and obviously she's an
American citizen too we discuss about
that later if you want but but what's
interesting is that I still feel like an
immigrant 20 years after I arrived in
the United States
maybe because sometimes I speak Spanish
maybe it's my accent maybe it's that I I
still dream about my house in Mexico
where I was born I mean when I when I
have these peaceful peaceful dreams it's
when I'm when I'm thinking about my
house in Mexico where I grew up Rylee
for 20 years and then my nostalgia I
mean it starts with my mouth watering
when I think of tacos al pastor I think
your nostalgia always starts in your
mouth and with their smells so if I
don't feel part of the United States
sometimes if I don't feel part of this
country sometimes then you might think
well maybe he feels pretty much a
Mexican well let me tell you when I go
back to Mexico I'm not exactly a Mexican
for my Mexican friends when I go back to
Mexico I am the one who left why did you
leave my friends ask me even my brothers
one brother Eduardo he asked me why did
you leave
he felt that he was so personal this
decision that I left that he was painful
for him for some people who are not my
friends they might think that I'm a
traitor it was an act of treason for
them that I left my own country why did
you leave Mexico we stayed we are making
five dollars a day why why did you leave
I mean and then for some of them I'm
manna green God Oh No which is a Mexican
who lives in the United States who feels
more comfortable maybe in the United
States so I'm sometimes I need her
there's a beautiful song by Facundo
Cabral and by just saying Facundo care
abroad for those of you who know him
already know that I'm over 40 actually
I'm 45 but these remember this song it
says no idea key nice idea yeah I am NOT
from here not from there and that's
that's how I feel sometimes and what's
really interesting is that my experience
I thought it was just an isolated
experience I thought I was rare oh I
thought I was strange
that I was the only one that did not
feel completely in Miami or in South
Florida or in the United States and then
I realized that that's not true that all
of us in the United States somehow we
are from other places
unless of course if you were a Native
American we came from other places and
and then I realize when I feel positive
when I feel an optimist that this is a
fantastic country that is going through
an incredible change that I am actually
part of that country and and I am a
representative of that change think of
the incredible changes that we've been
seeing in the last I don't know 20 years
do you know that more tortillas are
being sold and bagels in in the United
States that more salsa salsa mexicana
that more salsa is being sold and catch
you that's that's incredible and in the
past World Series I mean what are the
names of these fantastic baseball
players all of them are Latinos the
music is influenced by all these Latino
rhythms and then we have names in sports
and music like Stefan in Rodrigues
Gonzalez in Matias Ramos e-everything no
so what's going on in this country what
am i part of these well I am calling it
a Latino wave or a process of
Latinization this country is going
through a process of Latinization that
is going to change everything
think about the language Spanish is
being spoken of course in Miami and when
I go to Houston and in Los Angeles and
in New York and Chicago more than ever
even here in Miami when you go to
someplace even here in the Miami Book
Fair when you walk sometimes you only
hear Spanish and then I even hear some
people saying well the best thing about
Miami is that it's so close to the
United States well maybe that might be
true sometimes but think about it I mean
Spanish is being spoken in every corner
of the United States I came back last
week from North Carolina I was I spent
like two days in winston-salem every
single year the population in
winston-salem that Hispanic population
grows by 100% every single year even in
North Carolina you might think what are
Latinos doing in North Carolina I mean
they're working that's that's why we're
here but what I'm trying to say is that
again Latinos are everywhere Spanish is
being spoken in every single corner of
the United States even in the white
house george w bush he's the first u.s.
president who speaks spanish or should I
say the first u.s. president who thinks
that he speaks Spanish the I'm not sure
if I'm if I should say this but the
spokesperson for the Spaniard government
once told me and really interesting
anecdote in the White House President
Bush had invited lots of journalists
from Spain and then
ambush despite the fact of what you
think about his position in the war and
what he's been doing after that and we
can talk about it later
he is a very personable gentleman he's I
mean in he is someone that this first
impression is is very good very simple
very nice anyway
President Bush wanted to to show off
that he was the master of seven words in
Spanish so there were all these
correspondents from Spain in the White
House and he wanted to invite them for
lunch so here comes President Bush and
he said come on tengo mucho hambre
basically he was telling them I have a
lot of shoulders I guess that would be
the repeated translation what's
interesting is that this country is
truly been transformed by by Latinos
there's a process of Latinization that
is affecting everything and I'll think
of this by the year twenty one twenty
five unfortunately none of us are gonna
be here but in one hundred and twenty
two years from now there will be more
Hispanics than whites in the United
States again think about it what what's
the incredible demographic revolution
that we are living right now in this
country again in a hundred and
twenty-two years or maybe less if we
keep on having some so many babies
we love each other's honestly well
Latino families have more children than
than the rest of the population and of
course immigrants are coming on a daily
basis legally and illegally but in a 122
years from now there will be more
Latinos than non-hispanic whites in the
United States so we are in the middle of
an incredible demographic revolution and
then when I think a bit about this when
I think that this country's truly being
transformed that we Latinos are changing
the face of America then I start to feel
a little bit more at home I realize that
I am part of our this incredible
movement this process of Latinization
that is changing this this one
tastic country because just the other
day I was always writing an article
about the possibility than an immigrant
against someone being born in another
country could become the President of
the United States this would be
impossible even to discuss or to argue
in Japan or it would be impossible even
to discuss the possibility that someone
who was born in Nicaragua or Argentina
or Venezuela or Colombia could become
president of Mexico or for that matter
of any other country both their own and
these might be a possibility here in the
United States I mean Arnold
Schwarzenegger Governor of California
who would have thought of that mr.
Schwarzenegger I have many problems with
mr. Schwarzenegger especially his
positions in immigration he bought it
for Proposition 187 these think of if
this would have created that at least 1
million Latino children couldn't have
had access to schools or to hospitals
this is what mr. Schwarzenegger wanted
he he wants to militarize the border
between Mexico and the United States he
brought in Pete Wilson who according to
many people is the one of the worst
enemies that immigrants have ever had
anyway the problem is not at shorts or
[ __ ] what I'm trying to say right here
is that this is a fantastic country that
gives everyone the possibility to be to
be their best and maybe I am just part
of this incredible incredible revolution
that is going on in this country when I
arrived in in Los Angeles it was January
the 2nd 1984 and for many of us many of
us immigrants is like a second birth I'm
sure each one of you if you were born in
another country I'm sure you remember
when you came to this country cuando
llegué stirrers any other you remember
when you got here si you remember if it
was raining if it was
and I'm sure if I ask each one of you it
would be something very important today
you arrived in the United States I mean
we I came as a very poor student I
started working as a waiter I was making
$15 a day in one meal and that was the
most important thing so a country like
this one that gave me the possibility to
become an anchorman and to travel to 50
countries in two countries and to
interview 60 precedents and to go to
five Wars and I start out as a waiter
I mean it's very difficult to think of
any other country that could give you
this possibility and this is what's
really remarkable about the United
States that has given us all these
incredible possibilities to immigrants
that otherwise if I would have stayed in
Mexico I'm sure I would have been a very
sad journalist a very censor journalist
a very frustrated journalist and most
probably I could have been doing any
other thing but journalism so this is a
little bit part of my story I am someone
who even now I wanted to read you a
little bit about the the book it's
called no borders or a travis ando from
paris in espanol and right at the
beginning i I immediately let you know
that sometimes how I feel here in the
United States I I write I do not feel at
home never anywhere anyone watches me
anchoring the evening news dress in a
suit and tie my thing that I have made
it in that I'm not missing out on
anything but in fact I had yet to find a
place where I belong either tangible or
emotional I was having dinner last night
with my daughter and with a friend of
her Nadia and when you see us on TV and
I've been doing not if your only vision
for almost 20 years when you see us on
TV you might think that we are perfect
because we are wearing these great suits
we have a pretty good wardrobe and and
we get money for that
these silk ties we have makeup we have I
mean every hair is in its place
I mean and then we have this huge chairs
where you look like so tall one of the
most interesting experiences that I have
here in Miami is that when people seem
in the supermarket or walking
they say especially my Cuban friends
they say pero Mira lo que chica Tico
yeah I mean because what's going on is
that they think that I'm so tall and
muscular and that I'm I don't know that
I'm just perfect
think about it also we have so many
people working in the newscast nowadays
I don't know how many people do we have
Evelyn I don't know eighty a hundred
people working for the newscast just in
the newsroom that they look they they
made you look perfect I mean I have we
have writers and producers and I don't
take responsibility for for for that I
mean we are I don't take credit for that
we have so many people working for the
newscast that it's been seen not only in
the United States but also in thirteen
Latin American countries that they make
you look almost perfect but the truth is
that I'm very skinny the truth is that
I'm sure in the truth is that we are we
have problems and conflicts like any
other people and some of the conflicts
that I that I've been facing like any
other immigrant in this country or are
in this book no borders the subtitle is
a journalist search for home I think
that constantly constantly I am I am
looking for home and again at the same
time I realize that this country is
changing so much that the question is if
if we Latinos or Hispanics and by the
way that that's a really strange name I
mean if I ask any of you any of you
Latinos for Hispanics do you consider
yourself a Latino and say no no no no
I'm CUBAN no se understand your
staircase dominicano yo yo soy Mexicano
i KU bono tsukino Ibanez Solano's
puertorriqueños argentinos Mexicano
Pinole pero no se yeah Mariano steadies
hispano so Latinos
aloma corners podium at latinos para la
primera identificación
is del pi is your region the first way
to identify ourselves if with our
country of origin so so the question is
right now again we know that we're going
to be more there there's going to be
more Latinos than whites in this country
and please don't start running I mean
immigrants and Latinos we are not
criminals we are not terrorists and this
is our country too and we are not going
anywhere there are 10 million
undocumented immigrants in this country
and I've been arguing for four decades
now that they do this urban amnesty
immigrants both legal and undocumented
contribute more than ten billion dollars
to the economy of this country and all
these immigrants all those arrested in
Walmart stores they were not responsible
for what happened on 9/11 they were not
responsible for that
so I constantly repeat this message
immigrants are not criminals immigrants
are not terrorists
and after 9/11 to be an immigrant in
this country is not really that easy but
immigrants and Latinos we are changing
this country when when I arrived in 1984
a news director in Los Angeles told me
that I will never work in this country
he told me first of all you have a
pretty thick accent he was right about
that
even now mmm but then he told me
spanish-language media is going to
disappear forget about it
the radio in Spanish television in
Spanish newspapers in Spanish they're
going to disappear why he thought
because all Latinos we're going to
assimilate and all of us are going to
start speaking English just like the
Italian sea or the Germans and the poles
but let me tell you something surprise
surprise that has not happened I got a
job and he lost his job and at the same
time Germans did not have three
television networks in their own
language as we do now in Spanish
Italians did not have hundreds and
hundreds of radio stations in Spanish as
we do now Paul's did not have thousands
and thousands of publications in their
own language as we do now do now in
Spanish so we are truly transformed in
this country and maybe just maybe the
official language of the United States
will be English and Spanish that's at
some point I just want to went telling
you that when I feel at home is when I
sense that I can live in one country in
the United States and in two cultures at
the same time I am maintaining my first
language my traditions my customs my
friends but at the same time I do sure
and I really enjoy and I am proud of the
strengths and the freedoms and the sense
of justice that we enjoy here in the
United States so I might be on on one
foot in Mexico and one foot in the
United States but at the end I'm just
another americano so you know americano
so thank you all for coming and now of
course if you have some questions I'll
be glad to answer them thank you thank
you so much
if you have questions we can talk about
Bush Castro Hipolito Mejia what job is
whatever you want to us so what I'm
gonna do right now especially since
you're taping this also if the questions
in it's in Spanish I'll be answering in
Spanish if the question is in English
I'll be doing that in meanings so what
do you think okay go ahead the yellow
press Y in Spanish speaking is more
pronounced that you know it's in English
por que listen why is it that sensation
sensationalism is so much more announced
in Univ is showing Telemundo and we see
this more and more in your news there is
more sensational sensationalism you try
to take over people's feelings instead
of informing them you've lost the
capacity to inform lately that's my
impression right very certainly we waive
your sensationalism in the media but I
don't think you should blame in English
we have the same thing there is a
combination of entertainment news and it
affects everybody we're competing news
services with the English ones I'm
fighting against I'm competing with all
these other programs and ratings are
watching Dominic's when I get to my
office I see the ratings of the previous
evening and the content of the news that
we had but this is you're right this is
a trend that you see all around people
who are getting all their information
from TV are very I'm not very well
informed you have to listen to the radio
and you have to listen a lot to rate to
read a lot
Hotel America now first of all George
when I got to Los Angeles in 1954 there
were five Cubans in Los Angeles
myself consul general if there was a
minority here we were those there were a
million Mexicans and and with this Oh
dominating American culture I'm CUBAN
I'm white and I'm CUBAN I think you're
right in the sense that there has been
here in the United States recently in
the last 50 40 years an increase in the
number people coming from Latin America
bringing their culture their food this
country is this is a great country
because it's political system unless
it's because it's legal system is based
on the British system and not in the
dictatorial systems which we inherited
from Spain if there is any danger this
system here can be changed as a result
of Latin American and Spanish
immigration which I think if the system
that they now have here is changed into
a unitary system there will things will
go down here we notice here in the
States it seems that immigrants we bring
a tale and once you cross into the
border you want to close the doors
Maastricht estimate Oh God over one of
the saddest things that I have noticed
here both in the United States and
countries where there is a lot of
immigration after they arrived
immigrants went to Cozad or insist with
a case of Schwarzenegger he arrived in
1976 and he wants to close the doors to
not Austrians but to Latin American
Mexican and Guatemalan Central Americans
to think that Latin Americans are
different and you do not have the
capacity or the vendor's to be able to
live here in the United States I think
it's just the opposite we are
contributing in a incredible way to the
culture of this country in Mexico the
very same people used to throw trash or
load their horns we arrive here in the
United States we don't throw trash
we keep online and we don't complain as
before I think there is a double process
going on here Latinization of United
States and Americanization of our selves
9 in 10 Latins we speak both Spanish and
English but our kids speak more and more
English so we have influence on each
other I don't think the u.s. is going
down I think the United States has to
will win from our presence and I think
the first Hispanic president of the
United States is has been born already
we have fought so much a large
proportion of the population and we do
not have the same representation here I
think we're giving much more than what
we are taking from this country before
anything else
I admire your history and I have a
question that has nothing to do with
politics I'm interested in your opinion
as a parent
you talk about feeling at home and
finding your own home and this has to do
with the people who are surround us as a
parent how is it what is it that you do
to keep your habits your food and to
keep your family and to make your
children proud of all your culture I've
always tried to identify to link my
children and I don't know how to say
this Nicholas a Mexican live in a
Mexican living in United States my wife
is Puerto Rican and she and her parents
are Cuban Nicholas would be next 12 to
Rican and Cuban American and he's a new
American we're Mexican not to marrying
only marrying Mexican so we marry Cubans
and Puerto Ricans this combination
cultures is very important very nice and
I don't do this deliberately we speak
Spanish all the time and my kids answer
in English I think this is unavoidable
we try to keep them speaking Spanish I
read for them in Spanish we try to cook
Mexican food not because not
deliberately because that is what we
like to keep our tradition and to bring
and keep something that we brought from
our countries nothing special
up - question for you you're talking
about during your speech that the
everybody who arrives to this country
thinks that we should be doing something
else like being a waiter so being
something really a nice toddler why do
you think that we should change in our
countries for us to keep there and do
and leave and think that the best place
to be is there now here that's the first
question
and the second question is why do you
think that every most of the program TV
or radio programs which is about the bad
things not the good things why are there
so many immigrants coming to this
country the short answer is that this is
a great country but let me just go into
details if you are a Mexican worker or a
salad or a know or a Nicaraguan
campesino
and you are making five dollars a day at
the most maybe four dollars a day and
you have the possibility of making
exactly the same amount of money here in
the United States for in 40 in 40
minutes
or in one hour what are you going to do
another example in the last 20 years we
have seen this way of globalization
going through Latin America and what we
have seen is that now we have more
people who live poverty in Latin America
than 20 years ago so if you are a father
a father of three or a father of four
and you are making five dollars a day
think of I mean just think of what it is
actually to live with five dollars a day
or four dollars a day I mean what can
you buy with four or five dollars a day
so the reason why we have all these
undocumented immigrants coming on a
daily basis to the United States it
has to do nothing with politics or it
has nothing to do with police work it
has nothing to do with walls has
everything to do with supply and demand
as long as there are jobs for them here
in the United States and as long as they
are unemployed in their countries of
origin they're going to keep on coming
let me just give you an example just
today today is Saturday November the 8th
just today there were at least 1,000
immigrants today who cross the border
illegally from Mexico to the United
States while we are talking right now
there's some coitus pulling some pudgy
toes that's why they call em coyotes
poly arrows crow pollitos coyote Eskimos
tequila India Marlow yes you may know
they're crossing the border right now at
this moment at the same time think about
it what happened when when the I NS the
new AI NS detained 300 workers in the
Walmart stores after five years of
investigation they want to report 300
workers at the same time that same day
they detained these 300 workers 1,000 of
them cross the border illegally at the
same time every single year there's a
million and a half legal immigrants
coming to this country every single year
legally so what we see right now is that
going back to your question is that as
long as we have all these incredible
differences between Latin America and
the United States we're going to keep on
having immigrants coming to this country
I don't see anything nothing is going to
stop that so I'm simply suggesting two
things the first of all we need an
amnesty for the 10 million undocumented
immigrants who live in this country
believe me they're not going back if you
are making $80 a day $40 a day $50 a day
they are not going back they are sending
their dollars back but they are not
going back so it is incredible and it's
really shameful that in the United
States we have 10 million people living
under the shadows of society isn't this
supposed to be
a compassionate society I mean President
Bush wanted to be a compassionate
conservative I mean if you want to be
compassionate then given amnesty to ten
million undocumented immigrants they are
not going back what's more at a great
example of injustice in this country is
that children have the possibility to go
through elementary school in high school
despite the fact that they are illegally
or not in this country
but once they want to go to university
they gotta show that they are legally in
this country so we have thousands and
thousands of children graduating from
high school who are in this country now
because they wanted but because their
parents brought them from Latin America
and they just cannot continue starting
in in in the university so this is gonna
keep on having unless we have an amnesty
first and later on unless we have an
immigration agreement with Mexico first
and the rest of Latin America to have a
more orderly flow of immigrants at the
same time every single day one immigrant
dies in the border every single day more
more than 350 immigrants die on on a
yearly basis so this is going to
continue happening in this country
despite whatever whatever we do the
second question why we broadcast bad
news and not good news it has to do with
with many different things but news is
that when things change we are
interested in change in many times when
things change
that's exactly what we are reporting and
we are not saying 280 million people had
launched this morning that's not news
even though it might be news in Latin
America that everyone had had lunch or
dinner what's news is something that
it's affecting your life somehow
changing the world where you live and
unfortunately I agree with with you and
and the other person there's a lot of
sensationalism in our news media and
that's happening everywhere
but we should not be asked to do
something different from the English
language network that they're in doing
exactly the same but if you want to get
it straight reporting I think you can
watch noticiero Univision or you can
watch a Kia Ora
and then the BBC and watch ABC News and
watch Nightline and read The Herald and
read the New York Times and The Wall
Street Journal and times and in Newsweek
I mean do not depend only on one source
of information I mean if you depend only
on my newscast you will be you won't be
well-informed thank you
two more questions three more questions
yes my question has to do with Latin
America especially with what we have
seen all these changes especially in
some South American countries and a
survey surveyed recently according to
which that Americans are less and less
happy with satisfied with democracy
where are we getting true with the
opinion of the society and with the
weakness of these democracies this is a
very interesting question democracies
all around we have what the exception of
Cuba will have democracies in Latin
America Venezuela is an exception when
Chavez wants to be to be president until
2021 I interviewed him and he said that
he was not going to run again
he liked the here we have democracies
you know with the globalization changes
we cannot turn back we cannot start
globalization we cannot stop it
globalization in the first few stages it
has produced regeneration generated more
poverty with few exceptions for
Chile is one exception most of Latin
American countries have more poverty now
today what we many expected was that
democracy would resolve the problems of
justice poverty and electoral problems
no democracy has only served to resolve
a problem that way and government it
would be nice if the science democracy
in Mexico 2001 had brought prosperity
but we should not confuse things that's
the problem
next week in this very place the FDA a
meeting will be held the idea of free
trade for the Americas is very
interesting I was thinking to write
about this why is it that democracies
are failing why is it Sanchez de la
santé lost power in Bolivia why did
Mexico why did Manuel Lopez Obrador
from PR deal centered left party is
emerging leaving behind the
pre-incarnate why the changes saying
Argentina why is it that democracies are
feeling so much I think the answer is
poverty stupid remember Clinton's phrase
he used to say the economy is stupid I
think in our case the answer is poverty
is - the problem now for the fragility
of our democracies is that they have not
been able to generate prosperity that's
the reason we have more and more poor
and the right wing has not been
successful
now the left will emerge but don't get
scared because when we talk about the
left
here in Miami people think about the
Birdman we're talking about left wing
that will respect elections we're
talking about very different and
democracies and we're not going to
resolve this just in a flash if
democracy does not bring prosperity and
food and medicine for people Latin
America will go down when is it went
down we have to ask the question is when
was it that Latin America fell apart
if Latin America we're good shape we
would have stayed in Latin America but
no we're here I came from Mexico because
they had a problem of censorship but I
also trained it was easy to understand
that I would have more opportunities
here and then there that's what the US
gave me I think I'm getting into some
trouble here two questions more attacks
have affected Hispanic immigrants and
how is it that the Patriot Act has
hindered democracy in the United States
how is it do I have the time to
questions more I believe after September
the 11th it's very difficult to be an
immigrant in the United States they
tried to throw us out about 30 million
people they wanted to blame us the
immigrants put us has scapegoats for the
problems
it states ahead and this is a very
serious matter
this is one of the negative changes we
had since 9/11 before immigrants could
have a driver's license and not anymore
there was a chance of an immigration
agreement and not anymore Fox was the
best president of President Bush and now
it's a Tony Blair yes that's the case
many changes and for worse for many
years we have the resurgence of the i ns
rates this is very sad because this is a
country that has a fantastic free system
for the press is changing I feel it as a
journalist now people are criticizing
Bush but just after September the 11th
when the u.s. decided to attack
Afghanistan and Iraq you could not
criticize the president here in stories
that I wrote expressing doubts about the
war I would receive letters and emails
and people would send me email saying
little Mexican go back to your country
you're not you're anti-american so to
just do your normal journalistic work
and who raise questions is dangerous
they accuse you of anti-americanism like
kids were born here
this is also my country it's more and
more difficult and we noticed that there
is if not censorship at least
self-censorship cases of censorship
where are the dead of the Iraqi war
about 400 people have died I have seen
these people in Iraq dying
the Defense Department doesn't allow us
to film them they don't want to show
bodies arriving here to generate more
opposition and generate questions where
the WMD where where are the where's the
evidence that Iraq had nuclear material
seven in ten Americans still think that
Saddam Hussein had something to do with
the allah September 11th Saddam Hussein
was a killer brutal killer but was the
u.s. under the imminent danger of an
attack from Saddam Hussein probably not
so to raise difficult questions now it's
much more difficult than before and the
last last question perhaps if you give
me two questions first of all
congratulations for you were in Mexico
serving the future if Lopez Obrador
becomes president in 2006 he is elected
president with the kind of environment
that we have seen as the one we've seen
here when Lula took over in Brazil how
do you think the relationship between
Mexico and the US would be and your
question white anglo-saxon citizens that
think that immigrants or just plainly
minorities are threat to the you know
the ideal of the apple pie American Way
what what do you think will change that
as far as to stop a lot of the racism
that goes on and also I just wanted to
say that I assimilated what you were
saying about sometimes thinking that you
don't belong here or there because I'm a
product of a bi-racial couple I'm black
and Mexican so I just want to know what
you think about what what can be done in
order to
change that that way of thinking that a
lot of white Americans feel that just
because you're an immigrant or a
minority period you're not really
American I'll go to that question right
at the end and let me just answer this
in Spanish first yogurt okay I think
Mexico's here another politician a very
honest politician and he is one honest
politician and of course this requires
much more analysis precisely this
disenchantment with a traditional
party's first three and they lost
fortunately and then the bun we had lots
of boats with Fox and we thought he
would be able to change the country but
he has not been able to fulfill his
promises he promised so much he put the
Robertson Jo he would create lots of
jobs you have to blame not only him but
9/11 the Iraqi war president Fox wanted
to resolve the problems October the 2nd
1968 or he made so many promises and he
could not fulfill them and people
disenchanted and when there is this
disenchantment pursue Mexico Argentina
Bolivia Mexico and the pendulum starts
to change there is opportunities very
intelligent he started to do things as a
mayor he started to build another Lane
in the New Mexico City Beltway maybe a
populist idea but Mexicans I think 70%
of the people in the city of Mexico are
supporting him they see that he is doing
something is helping the aged people
when we have so many politicians
promising so much and doing so little
others who are promising more specific
and doable things and these people are
in the left they gain this is what we
now see as to the immigration agreement
I think people have been fighting for
this for so many years Latin America is
not priority for the United States I
wish I could tell you
so if Cuba was as important so important
to the United States they would have
done something if Mexico were nothing to
do now church they would have done
something kill us is focused on North
Korea Iran Iraq when Middle East is not
priority for the Americans think just a
summer I think that just to end this
conversation I think the melting pot in
the United States simply ran our run out
of steam Latinos we are not assimilating
like other groups of immigrants we are
assimilating I mean in in the way that
we are getting better salaries we are
getting better education that we also
want better jobs but at the same time we
are doing it our way we are not getting
lost in the mainstream we are giving
this country certain elements and
characteristics that will stay for the
rest of their history we are changing
this country for the better we are
changing the face of America and in
straight and it's great to be part of
this demographic revolution gracias por
venir when a notice thank you for coming
good night
Jorge Ramos is co-anchor of noticiero
Univision no borders is published by Rio
an imprint of HarperCollins visit
HarperCollins com for more information